so Robert Anton Wilson talks about
cultural reality tunnels right so think
of that metaphor think of that image
think of a tunnel of reality right a
single world view a single way of seeing
things right and it's the only reality
you know because you live within your
reality tunnel but when you're exposed
to new people to new ideas to different
ways of interpreting the world different
myths different customs right all of
these things what they do is unhand you
from the rigidity of the world you were
born into giving you what's akin to an
aerial view and it's a wonderful
experience because there's so much
insight to be gained from that change in
perspective something I often converse
with his own reality tunnel no I was
what I was saying is the importance of
going and exploring new lands right
visiting new places exposing yourself to
the unfamiliar right the idea that the
unexamined life is not worth living and
how important it is to do that everyday
to cultivate that practice to not kind
of take things for granted so to speak
to to to partake in a dialectical
pattern of reconcilable estrangement
with the world of everyday perception as
David Lentz and talks about this idea of
archetypal izing experience italicizing
experience you know witnessing the
specific but-but-but-but be holding it
as the universal everything stands more
clearly for all of its class this
particular path becomes the path my
particular life becomes the life we all
we mythologize ourselves and we
mythologize the world in order to enter
a kind of Garden of Eden where we can
extract meaning from our experiences
patterns from our experiences so that
life is not just mush but instead a
movie a journey motif a dream a dream a
dream within a dream row row row your
boat gently down the stream merrily
merrily merrily merrily life is but a
dream
keep being someday anything to help our
country we'd go who got hit whoever they
when used to play that Street Fighter
videogame didn't you go into that world
didn't you enter that ontology okay
everybody in their own trip catch you
guys later